we have this thing about him that I love
[Music]
me
Drake and Chloe Bailey just some of the
stars in Atlanta paying tribute to take
off
you know you get to share life-changing
moments with people who you change your
life for it's like what better way else
to do it with your family inside State
Farm Arena on Friday the late rapper's
cousin and bandmate offset with wife
cardi B at his side it's clear from the
events program take off celebration of
life was all about the music
[Music]
CeeLo Green came out and Justin Bieber
performed rapper De Brat shared a video
from outside the memorial
IP takeoff
Lucci bro
damn
we love you bro
Drake rescheduled his show this weekend
to honor the youngest member of Migos he
collabed with the group on walk it talk
it
[ __ ] it
as many as 20 000 fans listened as Drake
shared memories of the late rapper
whenever he would take his Shades off he
had this thing about him that I love no
matter what was going on around us he
was like always
kind of squinting but like his eyes were
wide open Chloe looked to Beyonce for
her tribute
[Music]
singing the icons 2013 ballad heaven
[Music]
couldn't wait for you
after news broke of tick-off's murder
Chloe wrote on Twitter my heart is
broken
[Music]
also in Atlanta signs asking for an end
to gun violence echoing the rallying
call from many who are mourning the 28
year old rapper I mean it's it's it's
it's devastating we've really lost
someone incredibly incredibly special
there we really really have it doesn't
make any sense you know we need more
love in this world and before you used
to think that United States was like the
most safety place in the world right
it's not even about if he's a musician
or not he's just like
this is not right
[Music]